I've been president and  commander-in-chief for over six years  now time and again I have faced  decisions about whether or not to use  military force it's the gravest decision  that any president has to make many  times in multiple countries I have  decided to use force and I will never  hesitate to do so when it is in our  national security interest I strongly  believe that our national security  interest now depends upon preventing  Iran from obtaining a nuclear weapon  which means that without a diplomatic  resolution either i or a future US  president would face a decision about  whether or not to allow Iran to obtain a  nuclear weapon or whether to use our  military to stop but simply no deal  means a greater chance of more war in  the Middle East